[Applause]
all right everybody it is time for
drew's news come rest your head on our
fluffy good news pillow and with me at
the desk is the one the only rossi russ
matthews hi everybody hi
oh i'll sleep on your pillow
i love a good pillow oh yes of course um
makes me think of planes trains and
automobiles those aren't pillows
um i like a nice hard firm pillow yeah i
like a nice stiff firm pillow
that's what i found out about myself at
27 years old um okay well first up we
have been waiting for years um for this
but it is here the blockbuster wicked is
finally being turned into an actual
movie finally
and pop sugar reports that rehearsals uh
start this july with our two brand new
witches cynthia irivo and ariana grande
and they say that they are spending
loads of time together to build up on
their sisterhood in preparation they
play elphaba and glinda and the witches
that originated at adina menzel and
kristin chenoweth they made those roles
famous the two ogs are big fans of the
new witches and they said may it change
your lives forever
um the way it has for us um have you
seen wicked have i seen wicked what
hello
i would no longer be able to be gay if i
hadn't seen wicked are you kidding me
this is one of the prerequisites
uh it might have turned me gay i don't
know
it is so good if you haven't been to to
see wicked anybody it is like an amazing
experience
and i and just think about this movie
you guys i mean cynthia revo oscar
nominee and then ariana grande hello
just here and don't look up too i mean
she's like yeah we know her as an
actress as well this movie is going to
be huge i think it'll be very popular
oh man i can't wait can't wait all right
moving on you know over the last couple
of years a lot of us have spent some
extra time in the kitchen upping our
cooking game you know i make my recipes
here i cook all the time yeah you do
well apparently now home chefs like me
are feeling very confident and martha
stewart reports a new survey found 63 of
home cooks said they could hold their
own against a pro chef in a cooking
competition that's right
okay 77 said cooking is one of their
most favorite activities 84 said the
best part is having someone
say that they love it and that it tastes
delicious yeah that's the right there's
nothing like when you make a meal for
someone and they're like that's so good
yeah i've had the opposite reaction many
times
i have
i actually it i'm still intimidated by
it i am like a humble home cook i love
food but for years i feel like i would
serve up what i concocted and the faces
were like
you know but no it's gotten better of
course i've tasted your food your food's
delicious it's gotten a lot better but i
i it is
your food's delicious thank you i still
will always have a little bit of that
like insecurity yeah see i watch the
food competition shows and i'm like girl
i could do that i know i could and can i
break some news right now nobody knows
this okay you know that i don't even
know if i can talk about this but what
are you going to stop me so
you know the show guys grocery games
yeti of course i love guy fieri well i
competed on an episode of guys grocery
games
can you even wait when does it come out
yeah i think it airs in april and i
can't tell you anything don't even look
at my face like i'm not going to give it
away how i do don't even look
i know you
you won
i don't know
you won i know it i don't i'm gonna make
a bet and then i'm gonna put some money
on it and i don't i i don't have any on
me but metaphorically speaking i will i
will take a bet and say you won well you
have to wait to find out i don't know
it's a lot of pressure in that clock
[Music]
you